Welcome to maps of meaning.
So the first question I guess I might
have is,
what,
why are you here?
Anybody got an interesting reason?
Uh,
order to be able to manipulate,
manipulate reality to my best interests.
A good plan except for the manipulate
part
is often it's better to work with
reality generally then manipulate it
because it tends to,
you know,
kick back.
Anybody else?
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
of course.
Actually changes for the,
for the better
author
really.
Is he any good
friend and you are no wonder he
threatens
to this course.
Six years ago in this course,
changed the way I see the world.
So I want to say after six years what
happens now?
You want to see if it'll change back.
Well,
that's good.
So why did you decide why?
Why after all this time did you decide
to come back?
Well,
I thought about the things you discussed
in the class over you over those six
years,
but now it's been a while.
And I want to refresh myself and see the
new experiences I have in your things.
I've learned how and what I can take
from it.
Now.
That's very,
um,
dedicated and hopefully useful to get a
spiritual awakening.
God,
I hope I didn't see that he did he.
Did he did any,
any,
like any description or
was it associated with an epileptic
seizure associated with vision?
Oh really?
Oh,
that's interesting.
Yeah,
that can get out of hand,
that sort of thing.
You know,
it's interesting.
I mean one of the things that I
experienced when I started to learn some
of the things that aren't going to talk
to you guys about is a very radical
increase in the intensity and clarity of
my dreams.
It wasn't pleasant by the way.
I
thought it was useful or most useful
things aren't that pleasant.
So you're in for some of the same
punishment.
I guess that's the plan.
Is that all right?
Anybody else
sort of have a independent interest and
existential psychology,
etc. So this seemed like a good place to
discuss it.
And I took care of all your previouS
class personnel personality.
When did you take that?
Couple of years ago.
Yeah.
Well it's a good preparation for this
class.
Like is there anybody here who doesn't
have any idea what this class is about
and just more or less showed up because
the time was right to or anything like
that.
So you don't really have any idea what
you're in for.
It looked cool and it's not also that
utfc
right.
Well I'm going to jump right into it
because why not and all spend.
So I'm going to talk to you for about
two hours and then you can have a break
and then I'm going to tell you what you
have to do in the class.
Okay.
So,
but by that time you'll know if you want
to take the class because you'll know
whether or not you were interested in
what I told you about.
So I'm going to video the clAss.
I always do that.
And so the vIdeos will be online.
the ones from previous years are online
as well.
So,
uh,
you know,
hopefully that'll be a useful resource.
Uh,
it shouldn't take me as much setup time
the next time is it did today,
you know,
I'm still getting used to this
equipment,
so.
All right,
so
I want to tell you why I'm telling you
the things that I'm going to tell you
mean
when I was approximately the same age
that you people are probably a little
bit older because I imagine your guys
around 21 or something like that.
I was probably about your age and then
maybe a couple of years older.
First year I was in graduate school in
particular,
which I guess was the 1985.
So I was 23 then,
um,
that was in,
like I said,
that was in 1985 and there were a couple
of times in the late 20th century where
the cold war,
it came to a peak and one time I guess
was probably in about 1957 when I think
it was 57.
I hope I have my dates right.
Was whenever stalad and announced that
he had developed a hydrogen bomb.
Now I don't know how much you guys know
about hydrogen bombs,
but all you really need to know about a
hydrogen bomb is that they use atom
bombs as a trigger.
So they're,
um,
they're quite the weapon.
And the ussr and the us made some very,
very big ones.
They're big enough to make the thing
that was dropped on hiroshima look like
dynamite,
you know,
so hundreds and hundreds of times
bigger,
maybe thousands of times.
It's been a while since I looked into
it.
and then in 1962 there was a cuban
missile crisis.
Not a good story about that.
So about 10 years ago I went down to
tucson,
Arizona to a conference on consciousness
there.
And they have that conference fairly
frequently in tucson.
It's,
it's become quite a popular conference
even though it isn't clear to me that we
know anything more about consciousness
than we did before the conference
started.
And two songs,
kind of an interesting town.
It's in the middle of the desert,
the desert,
you know,
it's a big sort of sorrow,
a road runner,
cactuses and um,
but it's also extremely dry there,
which is of course what you'd expect
given that it's a desert.
so one of the things the american do
with tucson is store old fighter planes
there.
And so there's a airplane museum,
which is an amazing place that has maybe
500 planes,
including john f kennedy's airforce one.
Right.
Which is the jet that he used to zoom
around the world.
it didn't even have a shower in it.
By the way.
It's funny because on the outside it
looks like a modern jet,
but to me inside it looks pretty much
like it was from world war two,
you know,
because 19,
62 is a lot closer to world war ii than
it is to now and all sorts of ways.
Even the.
The rockets that went to the moon look
like they were built by people who were
using world war ii technology,
right.
They're full of switches,
mechanical switches and there
it's pretty basic anyways,
as well as the airport museum,
which is a very interesting place.
There's be 52 bombers there and all
sorts of things.
Those things are huge.
There's also an airport graveyard where
they store old fighter jets and there's
a lot of old fighter jets,
so there's acres and acres and acres and
acres and thousands and thousands of old
mothballed fighter jets lined up in the
desert.
So that's kind of cool in a strange way.
But there was one other thing down there
that I went and saw,
which was a decommissioned nuclear
missile site and it was a,
a intercontinental ballistic missile
site.
10.
Those were built in the fifties and
early sixties.
And uh,
they were major league rockets.
Those things,
you know,
I think the silo,
because we could go into the cycle of
missiles weren't there anymore.
We can go into the silo and it was
certainly farther across in diameter
than this room,
I would think probably twice as twice as
large as this room.
So you can imagine how big a missile
that would be it.
It's not your grandmother's missile,
it's a major league piece of armament
and out on the grounds that these things
were underground deep underground
because they didn't want them to get
blown up if,
if,
if they were bombed.
So they buried them quite a long ways
down and to get into it you had to go
through this massive steel door that was
like a huge safe door except you know,
10 times as big and 10 times as thick
and out in the yard of the nuclear
missile site.
There were fences with barbed wire on
them of course.
And there was a missile cap,
you know,
so it'd be the nose cone of the missile
down.
Some of these missiles had single
warheads and which were more than
sufficient to demolish a city and some
of them had multiple warheads so they
would shoot out into space and then come
back into earth and then they
essentially break apart or,
or disperse into multiple missiles and
then you could really bomb the hell out
of whatever you were going to bomb
instead of just destroying one city.
And so the nose cone was sitting out
there and that was a pretty freaky
looking thing.
I'll tell you,
like it was big.
It was about seven feet high I would
think.
And maybe about the same amount of
cross.
And it was made out of this plastic,
kind of a variegated plastic material
that was about three quarters of an inch
thick and then it would melt off of
course on re-entry because as I said,
these things shot out into space and so
I was kind of unnerving really in a
serious way.
And then,
so we're at the missile site and you
know,
I mentioned your grandmother's missile
and that there was actually a reason for
that.
It was a bit of foreshadowing because it
was a very funny place because at the
front of the missile site there was sort
of this museum set up,
you know,
and it had pictures of reagan and
gorbachev on it because they
decommissioned the missile sites.
You know what,
when,
when detente occurred and then when,
when perestroika hit and the soviet
union started to collapse and so there
was all these pictures of reagan and
gorbachev from 1984.
And so the museum was kind of like a
time capsule of 1984.
And the people who were running it were
like retired arizona's.
And they were like your grandparents,
assuming you have retired.
Arizona's for your grandparents,
but they're real friendly and you know,
they were pretty happy to show you their
nuclear missile museum and it was sort
of like being in their rec room except
that it was a nuclear missile site,
you know,
and they were hospitable and it was
weird,
you know,
it's like welcome to,
you don't welcome people to a nuclear
missile sites,
you know,
it's just not,
it's just not reasonable.
So it was very disconcerting and it was
disconcerting that it was locked in the
19 eighties and then it was
disconcerting that it was friendly and
hospitable and you know,
they were kind of proud to show it off
and happy to be there.
And then when you went down into the
nuclear missile silo,
proper,
the control center,
it's sort of like,
like star trek,
you know,
from 19,
66 or 1967,
except more primitive.
I don't remember if the star trek
control command area was modeled after
the nuclear missile site control systems
or if it was the other way around,
but I suspect it was.
They were modeled after the nuclear
controls,
but that was really 1950.
It's like the whole place was painted in
that pastel green,
you know,
late fifties and early sixties.
People really liked,
and it was,
it had this 19 fifties,
um,
what would you call it,
an aesthetic and you wouldn't
necessarily think that a nuclear missile
site would have an aesthetic,
but it does.
And it looked like high tech,
1957 in 1957 technology.
And so they brought you into the control
room and the control desk was probably,
or the molecule or whatever you might
call it,
was about three times as long as this
maybe four times.
Well,
not pretty impressive piece of
machinery.
And the way you launch the missiles was
not too secure in my humble opinion.
What happened was one guy wore the key
around his neck and another guy who wore
the key around his neck.
And then in order to launch the sites,
you had to put the keys in the same
time.
And they were far enough apart so nobody
could stretch their arms,
you know,
which was the kind of the high tech part
of it.
So.
And you had to put the key in and then
you both had to turn the key for 10
seconds.
Okay.
So now one of the things that you may
know about ballistic missiles or you may
not,
is there not cruise missiles?
Man,
onCe you set those things off,
they're not coming back.
There are bullets.
That's what makes them ballistic.
So you know,
if you aim a gun at someone and you
shoot and you decide halfway when the
bullets halfway there that maybe that
wasn't the good thing to do,
it's a little late because you're not
telling that bullet to come back.
And it's the same with ballistic
missiles and those things are going a
lot faster than the bullets.
You know,
like at 22 bullet goes about the speed
of sound,
600 miles an hour or so.
But a ballistic missile,
nothing has to go seven miles a second
to get out of the gravity of theory.
Now I'm not sure they go quite that fast
because that's escape velocity,
right?
You need to do that to get out of the
gravitational wealth.
But to get out there into space,
you have to be damn close to seven miles
a second.
And so it's a bullet,
very large bullet with a very explosive
hand on it going seven miles at second.
And once You turn those two keys,
man,
it's good.
That's it.
There's no,
there's no turning back.
That's that.
And so theY took us through a simulated
launch,
which still kind of,
it's still an uncanny feeling,
remembering that,
you know,
because it was,
it's a hell of a thing to apprehend.
And then they told us that the keys Were
in once,
right?
So we were 10 seconds away.
Now they wouldn't tell us when,
but we know it was during the cuban
missile crisis.
So,
you know,
there are a couple of times in the
latter part of the 20th century where we
made it through,
uh,
like the eye of a needle.
We barely bloody well made it.
And the cuban missile crisis was one of
those points.
But the,
the early eighties things were heating
up pretty badly to,
you know,
in about 1984,
there was a movie that came out called
the day after you guys probably don't
know about the day after,
but it was the most watched movie that
had ever been broadcast on tv at that
point.
And basically what it showed us,
what a city would be like the day after
the United States had been bombed into
total desolation by a soviet missile
attack.
And you know,
it was a pretty hair raising movie.
And one of the things that was quite
interesting about it was the ronald
reagan later said that he watched that
movie and that was actually part of the
reason that he entered into detente
talks with,
with the soviets.
Now you know,
reagan and being basically scaring the
hell out of the soviets.
He called him an evil empire,
which liberals weren't very happy about.
But the soviets man,
they were an evil empire.
There's absolutely no doubt about it.
You know,
it's not obvious how many people the
soviets killed during their,
their communist revolution.
And in the years following that.
But the estimates range from 20 to $60
million now,
that's a lot of people like even if it's
$20 million,
that's three times as many people were
killed in the holocaust,
you know the song,
the soviet starved 6 million ukrainians
in the 19 thirties and that was just to
get warmed up.
So the idea that the soviets were an
eviL empire,
it's like it's a strong word,
but there's absolutely no doubt that it
was true.
And the more we learn about what
happened,
especially during the this period,
although lennon was no picnic,
you know,
he,
he pretty much created the stalinists
monster that followed him.
The more we learned about it,
the more horrible if it comes,
you know,
and the soviet system was operated,
the economy fundamentally ran on slave
labor,
you know,
for what economy there was.
And you know,
what happened with reagan and park was,
well first of all,
the soviet union was falling apart
because there's just so long you can
keep a sinking ship afloat,
you know,
and something that big can die 20 years
before it falls over.
You know,
a system like that can stumble along
half got it and,
and still manage and so by the time
reagan come along,
the thing,
it probably pretty much burned itself
out as a consequence of internal
contradictions,
but he ramped up the american military
spending to a staggering degree and part
of the idea behind that,
at least that's what republicans would
have everyone believe in,
it might be true,
was that they're just going to spend the
russians right into bankruptcy and they
basically did.
and so that was that for the soviet
union and it fell over 1989,
which was like,
that was a good day.
That was a really good day.
And the weird thing is no one saw it
coming,
you know,
and that was,
that was,
that was shocking.
It was like one day the soviet union was
there and the next day the soviet union
was gone and there were no cia analysts
that said,
hey,
yeah,
there were about ready to crumble.
You know,
you just have to blow on them and
they'll fall over.
It was a shock to everyone,
you know?
And then it was very iffy in the
aftermath whether or not it would hold
'em yeltsin who was a terrible drunkard,
but actually a pretty courageous while
he was a russian,
you know,
he was a pretty courageous guy and he
faced down a reestablishment by the
totalitarians on a tank,
you know,
so that was good for him because that
was pretty frightening to.
Anyway.
So I'm telling you all this because when
I grew up,
most of the people I knew were convinced
that there was no bloody way we're gonna
make it to the 20th century,
you know,
when I think I can remember discussing
this with all of my friends frequently,
you know,
and um,
some people kind of used that as an
excuse not to get their life together.
Like,
you know,
what the hell's the point,
we're going to blow ourselves up
anyways.
So,
you know,
I might as well drink until I fall over.
And you know,
that's not particularly a moral way of
looking at it.
But I'll tell you,
like,
there,
there was no shortage of thinking that
this was so insane that it was going to.
Siri certainly am an absolute
catastrophe.
And it damn near did like it wasn't some
kind of collective delusion,
you know,
there,
there were times,
in fact,
there was a story recently published
about it,
uh,
a russian general who was given the
order to launch the missiles.
Uh,
there was a mistake and reading on their
display,
showing the missiles were coming from
north America across the pools into
Russia.
And he was told to launch and he didn't
like,
well,
good for him,
you know,
but that's a little too close really.
You know,
and there's all sorts of other crazy
things that happened during that period
of time.
So for example,
I read this book by an ex kgb guy who
said he worked in a biological warfare,
a lab in the soviet union,
'em.
They'd killed a number of people by
accident when some of their bugs got
out,
you know,
on the new order of 500 people,
which is a lot of people,
but it's not,
you know,
like 250,000 people,
but it's a lot of people.
But what those geniuses we're trying to
do mr krause,
ebola,
smallpox,
smallpox is unbelievably.
The combination of smallpox in ebola is
extraordinarily easy to transmit and
very,
very fatal.
And so they were trying to cross it and
then aerosolized it so that you could
distribute it in canisters and blow it
over cities,
you know,
nice bit of scientific investigation.
Perfectly reasonable scientific
question.
Can it be done a little sketchy on the
moral side you might say.
So,
you know,
it was a pretty crazy period of time and
I mean,
all human history.
What does the esky say about human
history?
The one thing you can say about that,
it's not rational,
right?
He said the very word sticks in your
throat.
So,
you know,
it's always been crazy and it's crazy
now,
but it was really crazy then.
And so we got through that and thank
god,
you know,
as far as I'm concerned,
the world is a lot better place now than
it was.
Well it is 30 years ago,
40 years ago,
50 years ago,
things are way better now.
You know,
you hear a lot of doom and gloom about
how we're going to destroy the planet,
but,
but we probably aren't,
you know,
the population is going to stabilize out
at about 9 billion.
That's what the projections look like.
We already have about seven.
We can handle another two.
There's kind of,
there's gonna be some extinctions were
eating up the ocean like insane.
You know,
purina,
that's mostly a fault of public policy.
But it looks like we're probably going
to squeak through the century with a bit
of damage and then things will settle
down.
You know,
it's,
it's highly probable if there's anything
vaguely human left in 100 years that the
big problem will be.
That population is rapidly decreasing.
That's already happening in european
countries is happening in Japan.
It's going to happen in China.
So by the year 2100,
the most populous country in the world
is going to be Nigeria,
not China.
China's gonna lose people like mad
because they had one child policy,
right?
And everybody in China is getting old so
you know that it's not going to be hiker
populated.
So anyways,
so I was interested in all of this
because,
you know,
I kind of felt that I'd grown up,
I didn't feel like I'd grown up under a
shadow.
I grown up under it's shadow,
you know,
and it was something in the back of our
minds all the time.
And then there was a question underneath
that,
a couple of them and one was
how,
why is this possible?
How is this possible?
How could it be that the world could
divide itself up into two armed camps
like hyper armed camps,
right?
tens of thousands of nuclear missiles
more than enough to wipe out the enemy
many times over.
I don't remember what the american
arsenal peak debt,
but I think it was more than 50,000
nuclear weapons.
I don't know if there are 50,000 towns
in the soviet union,
you know,
maybe they were going to bomb bomb
moscow 50 times or something,
but after the first two or three years,
probably more or less irrelevant.
So it was really,
it was really crazy.
You know,
I don't know if you know this,
but I believe this was during the
kennedy era.
I hope I've got thiS right.
one of kennedy's genius boys came up
with the [inaudible] kennedy's
administration was run by a lot of
harvard graduates and ivy league
graduates and so,
you know,
they were supposed to be pretty
intelligent,
but intelligence and wisdom are not the
same thing.
But anyways,
um,
they established a policy which was
called mutual assured destruction,
which means if you hit me,
I kill you and then you kill me.
And so it'd be better if we just didn't
bother.
and the acronym was mad,
right?
Mutual assured destruction.
It's like,
you know,
just thinking about that it,
it's a chilling thought.
It's like what horrible entity thought
that up as a joke.
You know,
when you think,
well,
does that sum.
It says that some politician's idea of
width,
like where'd that come from?
So that's a hell of a thing to make a
joke about,
you know,
mad.
Well,
that was right.
It was definitely mad,
you know,
and the odd thing is,
is that we didn't blow ourselves up and
we didn't have a third world war and you
know,
you,
you can't make a solid claim that the
invention of nuclear weapons was
necessarily the worst thing that could
have happened,
you know,
because even the soviets who were
completely insane,
and of course the model was to probably
even worse.
They weren't insane enough to start a
nuclear war.
Now stalin,
there's evidence,
there's debate about it,
but there was,
and there's evidence that stalin was
basically murdered partly by khrushchev,
was who was his,
who was his successor,
um,
when stalin died,
khrushchev and three other people were
in his house and what happened in
stalin's house the night he died is not
clear.
But I read a book recently called
stolen.
Interestingly enough,
that was written by a guy who had access
to the full communist party archives,
you know,
which was relatively new thing and that
was his conclusion and he also believed
that stalin was gearing up to do it,
an invasion of europe and that he didn't
give a damn how many cities would have
to be bombed in order for the soviets to
roll through.
And stalIn.
He was like that,
you know,
stalin was perfectly capable of taking
entire nations of people out in eastern
europe by train and shipping them out to
siberia in the middle of the winter with
nothing to eat and no tools and letting
them live,
which of course they didn't.
And that meant women,
children,
men,
you know,
shorn of all their belongings and thrust
out into the middle of nowhere to perish
or,
or live as they saw fit.
And if they perished so much,
the better as far as stalin was
concerned.
And so he wasn't exactly the sort of
person.
The idea of a nuclear war would
necessarily stop.
And it's certainly possible that that's
what he was hoping for.
You know,
because when we look at people like
stalin and hitler,
we think,
well,
you know,
thereafter world domination,
and you think,
well in some sense that's kind of a
positive motivation,
right?
I mean not really,
but it's like if you have a core vat say
and someone steals it,
you can think,
well,
I know why they stole it.
They want to have the corvette,
you know,
it's,
it's an understandable motivation to
want power.
It's not necessarily an admirable one,
although sometimes power is a perfectly
reasonable thing to pursue,
but I don't have any idea why we ever
assumed that those guys were after
victory.
Like you should never make the
presupposition that everyone is out to
When some people are out to lose and the
more people they can take wIth them,
the better.
You know.
And when hitler died,
he committed suicide in a bunker way
down below berlin.
West berlin was on fire and europe was
burning.
It's like,
as far as I can tell,
that was exactly what hitler was after
right from the beginning.
You know,
he was interested in fire as a purifying
agent.
You know,
he's a fire worship or in some sense,
because if you look at the nuremberg
gatherings of the nazis,
you know,
they're spectacular,
spectacular celebrations,
unbelievably dramatic and impressive,
and they frequently featured fire and
fire's up purifying agent,
you know,
and hitler,
by the end of world war ii was,
he was pretty contemptuous of the
germans because they really hadn't
served him well.
It wasn't like he thought,
well maybe it wasn't such a good idea to
start a whole second world war,
you know,
because he was a little on the
narcissistic side we might say.
But by the time the russians came
marching in,
in Germany was in ruins.
Hitler was perfectly happy to have the
allies tromp all over the citizens
because that's what they deserved
anyways.
And so that's the sort of guy he was.
And so why we would assume that he
wanted to win just because that's what
he said is something I've never been
able to understand.
You know,
the kids who shot up columbine didn't
want to,
when they wanted to kill as many people
as possible to make a point and then
they wanted to kill themselves just in
case you didn't exactly get the point
and the point was the more destruction
the vendor and if I asked to go along
with it,
hey,
no problem.
That just makes me a little bit more
serious than I might've otherwise be.
And so those sorts of motivations are
not pleasant to understand,
but we have enough documentation about
events like that,
you know,
especially the mass killings.
Those guys have written down exactly why
they do it.
Now.
I have some excellent books on
extraordinary vengeful,
a map serial killers at mass murderers.
I know exactly how they think.
There's a great book if you're
interested in this sort of thing called
pans,
ram p a n zed r a,
m and carl pants.
Ram waS a serial killer and rapist who
lIve pretty much early in the 20th
century and he was a tough delinquency
sorta kid from a large family and when
he was,
you know,
13,
14,
they sent them off to some reform school
and it was run by the same sort of
people that run canada's residential
schools and you know,
so those were basically predators on
children and of course he was raped and,
and,
and brutalized and tormented and in all
sorts of horrible ways and,
but he was a tough guy and when he came
out he decided that,
you know,
the human race really wasn't worth that
much and that he was going to reek as
much mayhem as he possibly could for the
rest of his life.
He raped a thousand men,
killed dozens of people.
He kept track of the dollar value of the
buildings.
He burned down like this was a serious
scott and he wasn't.
He was bent on destruction and that's
that what his.
What were his dying words?
First of all,
there was a committee,
I believe,
of women who intervened on behalf of him
because they were anti a capital
punishment and he said to them,
if I remember correctly that he wished
the human race had one neck so that he
could put his hands around it and
squeeze.
So you know,
that was his way of pointing out to the
people who didn't think that maybe
capital punishment was justified in his
case that maybe they weren't thinking
clearly.
And then to the hang man,
he said,
hurry up you who's your bastard?
I could kill 10 men in the time it takes
you to hang me.
So you know,
you don't get a statement like that from
someone who isn't thoroughly committed
to what he's doing.
So the situation in the world found
itself involved in really had me
thinking,
you know,
part of it was,
well,
what the hell is going on with all these
weapons and how can it possibly be that
anyone thinks that that's a reasonable
solution?
And how did it come about that this
could even occur?
And what are we thinking?
And then so there was that and then
there was also the why are people so
damn convinced on each side of this
argument that they are right enough to
risk everything for,
you know,
which is a perfectly good question.
And then there was the malevolence
issue,
like how much of this has nothing to do
with wanting to see your side when and
everything to do with wanting to see
everything lose,
you know.
And then,
oh,
then there was another issue which was,
well our are both sides wrong
are both sides,
right?
Because that's more of a cultural
relativist approach,
right?
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
The communists believed one thing and
the bloody capitalist believe another
and they're just as bad.
And who were you lIke,
who believes what is completely
arbitrary because belief systems are
arbitrary and so maybe they're both
writer,
they're both wrong.
And I thought,
well,
either of those conclusions was pretty
damn dismal because if they're both
right,
then well,
what are you going to do?
Have them talk it out.
I don't think so.
And if they're both wrong,
well that's not much better.
And then if one's right in the other's
wrong,
well,
does that mean anything like is it
possible for one belief system to be
more right than another belief system?
Because of course that's certainly not
attendant of moral relativism and you
might think about that as the standard.
Certainly the standard intellectual
approach to morality and probably has
been for the last hundred years,
I think by the way that that's a
reprehensible morality
w
and what I'll tell you as the course,
whereas we move through the course
because one of the things are trying to
find out was why is what we were
fighting for,
you know,
assuming that you give the west a bit of
the benefit of the doubt and assume that
some of the things that we stand for,
we actually stand for and aren't just
posturing and parading.
Was that grOunded in anything or was it
just arbitrary opinion?
So that's what we're going to talk
about.
We're going to talk about that,
why people believe the things they
believe,
what psychological function at the
beliefs,
uh,
perform.
We're going to talk about malevolence
and aS far as I can tell like
malevolence is the willingness to do
evil and I think the best is the best
definition of evil.
That,
and I thought about this for a long
time,
it's like actually what constitutes
evil.
It's complicated and we'll talk about a
lot,
but I think if you want a one line
summary,
it's the desire to do harm for the sake
of the harm.
So you have to think about it as a kind
of art form.
So like if you're.
look,
if,
if you have a terrorist and you think
he's hitting an atom bomb in a stadium
and you think,
well,
he's not going to tell me you have good
evidence,
he's not going to tell me unless I
torture them.
I don't think you should torture because
tortures wrong.
But you know,
if you're doing that and you really
believe these hidden atom bomb in a
stadium,
well at least you have some
justification for what you're doing and
it's not necessarily that what you're
doing is evil.
It might be wrong,
it might be misguided.
I mean,
who's to say in a situation like that,
it should certainly be illegal,
but at least you can say,
well,
there is a plausible explanation for it,
but lots of situations where there is
absolute horror,
there's no plausible explanation for it
whatsoever.
So I can give you an example.
so for example,
one of the things that used to happen in
auschwitz,
if I remember correctly,
I don't know what you guys envisioned
when you envisioned concentration camps,
you know,
like concentration camp.
It's a funny name first of all because
it's not really at camp.
You know what I mean?
But a concentration camp is like a
prison,
you know,
and that's easy to scan,
easy to envision them,
like a prison,
those bloody things where cities,
right?
They have tens of thousands of people in
sort of their massive.
At least they were large towns.
So these are very big places anyways.
You know,
at the typical concentration camp,
the trains would come rolling in and of
course people have been packed into the
damn trains,
like,
well worse than animals.
They'd be packed standing and lots of
people just died in the cars because
especially if they are old or little in
or had some respiratory problem or
something like that because they'd
overheat if they were cramped right in
the middle of people or they'd freeze to
death on the outsIde because they're
pushed right against the wood or you
know.
But that was okay.
It just made the job easier when they
finally landed at auschwitz,
you know,
and then once they were in auschwitz,
well then the guards used to like to
play tricks on them.
And so one trick would be to get some
poor son of a bitch who,
you know,
being torn away from his country,
who'd had his family destroyed,
who knew where he was going,
who was half dead for six different
reasons.
Who iS among strangers.
Maybe he dIdn't even speak or she didn't
even speak the language that was most
common there,
you know,
guarded by absolutely ruthless
barbarians who wanted to do nothing else
but make people as miserable as possible
in is in the most creative
possible ways.
And so what they would do with some of
the prisoners would say give them wet
sacks of salt.
and so those weigh about 100 pounds and
they'd have them carry them from one
side of the compound to the other.
Well,
you know,
that's not so bad when you're really,
really Innovative in your capacity to
perpetrate evil.
But the next thing they did was carried
them back.
And so you think about that,
you know,
and this is something half to understand
if you really want to understand evil,
is that it's an aesthetic.
It's An art form.
You know.
And the reason that that was such a
terrible torture was,
well,
partly because these people were already
ruined and 100 pounds is a lot of salt
and maybe it was winter and they didn't
have any shoes.
And you know,
like it's just brutal labor.
But solzhenitsyn,
when he wrote about the gulag
archipelago,
he said,
you know,
even if you were a prisoner,
they were having you build a wall.
You can at least take some damn pride in
building the wall.
You know,
you could lay some bricks out and you
can think,
well this sucks and it's really horrible
and everything,
but you know,
I built a straight wall that something.
BuT if you have to take a sack of wet
salt,
the one side of the compound and then
carry it back,
like the net consequence of that is
zero,
right?
It's zero.
Then of course the famous signs on the
outside of the concentration camps were
work will set you free right now.
That's another joke.
It's like mutual assured destruction,
you know,
and the only way you can,
a job like that is st stanek,
there's no other way to think about it.
The a job like that comes out of the
deepest depths of human malevolence and
then the work that sets you free when it
wasn't even work,
right?
It was,
it was at parody of work and the purpose
of the work was to destroy you,
but not quickly because that's not as
terrible as destroying you slowly,
you know.
So these are very,
very terrible things.
And so part of what I thought about in
relationship to people's belief systems
was,
you know,
people are territorial chimps,
I don't know if you know this or not,
but chimps basically go to war.
Jane goodall diScovered that a couple of
decades ago and it really,
really was hard on her because she was
kind of a ruse soviet.
So for those of you don't know joe,
john jacques rousseau is a french
philosopher and,
you know,
french philosophers have a lawful lot of
sins on their conscience.
And then of course it was.
So,
it was certainly one of them because
russell was the first,
like what fully articulate promoter of
the idea that human beings were
basically good.
So we know we had a good soul in a moral
sense,
but we were corrupted by our social
institutions,
you know.
So,
uh,
so,
you know,
as far as russo was concerned,
it was kind of a noble savage idea.
You know,
like the human being in their raw form
has a pure soul.
And then you know,
you,
you give them to parents and you've
given them to teachers and you know,
they'd get into politics and there's
group disputes and then they get all
corrupted,
you know,
and well,
that's,
I don't even know what to say about that
except that it's absolutely moronic
keynote.
But it's an appealing proposition if
you're naive optimist.
I mean,
first of all,
it doesn't explain where malevolence
comes from because the people created
the institution.
So you know,
it just puts you into an infinite
regress chicken and egg if the
institutions are reprehensible.
BUt the people who built them aren't.
Then where did the reprehensible element
that the institutions come from,
you know,
he might think it's an autogenerated
consequences of organizing people.
But you know,
it's a pretty specious theory.
So I'm of course hit.
He had a counterpart of philosophical
counterpart,
Thomas Hobbs and hobbs said basically
exactly the opposite,
that,
you know,
people were vicious and cruel unless you
put them in straight jackets
fundamentally and made them obey.
Then everything was going to go
immediately to help you know.
And when,
when you saw what happened in Iran after
the americans won't stand in,
the power structure disintegrated,
you know,
it was a hell of a lot more like hobbs.
Then it was like rousseau,
right?
You took out the,
the,
the tyrant at the top.
And it wasn't like everybody got all
peaceful and loving.
All of a sudden it was like absolute
chaos reign.
So,
you know,
of course you can rationalize that.
But anyways,
roost.
So by the way,
had five children by a made a
illiterate,
made that,
that it was as mr.
And he put every single one of them in
orphanages where,
of course they perished because
orphanages at russo's times were not
exactly,
you know,
a luxury resort.
And even up until the beginning of the
20th century,
most children who are under one years of
age who were in care institutions died
partly disease and that sort of thing.
But often because they just weren't
touched,
they weren't cared for physically.
Even if they were fed and you know,
200 years ago they weren't even fed.
So
anyway,
so you know,
but nonetheless,
you know,
people have people
maintain the optimistic idea that human
beings were basically good and that they
were corrupted by institutions.
It's a common idea among,
I think it's a very common idea in
universities,
you know,
because university people are always
complaining about the corrupt nature of
this institution and that institution,
you know,
well they sit here in the warm with the
electricity on,
you know,
surrounded by wealth that characterizes
maybe one 10th of one percent of the
entire world's population and you know,
they complained about how we'll press
they are and how will we get no nasty?
The institutions are,
it's like,
yeah,
well you actually have been to a nasty
institution,
cause nasty institutions.
They get pretty damn bad and most of the
institutions in the world are like that.
So it isn't exactly clear that people
are pristine in their heart and then
corrupted by institutions.
Although I'm sure that happens patent
depends around,
for example.
So anyways,
this has been a line of philosophical
speculation.
That's,
that's,
I would say constituted one of the
unspoken fundamental assumptions of,
of western intellectuals in particular,
and jane thought,
you know,
it'd be in many ways the same way she
thought chimps were basically at all.
They're just animals.
They are okay.
They coexist relatively peacefully with
one another,
you know,
even,
um,
Carl Rogers,
who I talk about a bit in my personality
class,
you know,
he basically thought that people were
fundamentally good and that institutions
make the badge.
But uh,
the problem is you look at chimps and a
fair bit like us,
you know,
bonobos,
you can look at them too,
and they're,
they're genetically quite related to us
and they're quite a bit different than
chimps,
but.
So we're sort of a weird mixture of the
two in some sense.
But champs,
like those things,
there is no evidence that they really
have any internal control over the
regression at all.
You know,
there was a horrible case about two
years ago where a woman was interacting
with the chimp and it tore her to pieces
and they can do that man.
Like it took her face right off and they
have the strength of about six men,
like an,
an,
uh,
an adult male chimp can break a 300
pound test cable,
you know,
those things are really,
really strong and they are not friendly,
you know,
like.
So in arnhem zoo for example,
there's been a troop of chimps there
that have been followed by it,
extremely brilliant primatologists named
frans de waal who's work I would very
highly recommend.
The wall is a very smart guy and he's
looked at the origins of morality and
chimpanzees,
you know,
from a biological perspective,
it's very,
very nice work,
very,
very clearheaded.
But you know,
he's recounted absolutely horrific
stories of chimpanzee behavior.
So one of the stories he talked about,
for example,
was,
you know,
when you kind of have this idea that
there's a mail chimp hierarchy,
it's roughly true.
There's a female hierarchy too,
but the males and the chimp world
anyways tend to be the dominant ones.
And you know,
you kind of think of a dominant primate
like a prize fighter,
you know,
pretty much he's ruling because of his
physical prowess.
Now that turns out not to exactly be
true,
but in this particular case,
the guy who was running the chimp troop
was a bit of a bully and he wasn't very
good at making friends,
you know,
and that's not such a good idea because
no matter how tough you are by yourself
to weaker guys can probably take you
out.
And that's what happened during friends
to wall observations and two chimps
attack the leader and they had a
coalition.
They were grooming each other.
They repels,
you know,
in chimps are pretty good at remembering
like risk reciprocal relationships and
having friendships really like they have
a very highly social structure.
Hey,
just tore him apart like the things they
did to him like you don't even want to
talk about.
And so chimps have really no upper limit
on their capacity for aggression and
when they hunt,
because chimps,
honda and they liked me,
they often call us monkeys and they
weigh about 35 pounds,
like a cola.
This monkeys a major league animal and
they eat those things alive and they
scream while they're being killed.
And that does not slow the chimps down
one bit.
So it's not obvious that the chimp is
really a creature of a lot of empathy,
especially the males.
The females are likely more empathic
because they have to deal with infants
for longer periods of time.
What seems to inhibit the aggression of
mail chimp's isn't anything they hold
internally.
It seems that when they get hyper
aggressive in the truth,
the truth gets more and more agitated,
basically shuts them down.
So you can imagine maybe you're in a
rough bar and some dingbat who is,
you know,
half psychopathic and has had two pints
of alcohol is starting to cause a
tremendous amount of trouble and he's
not going to shut himself down,
but the rest of the troop might.
And that kind of means that the control
over the aggression is externalized.
It's not a consequence of super ego
control.
And we like to think that we actually
control our own aggression,
but I'm not so sure about that.
You know,
if you read things like there's a great
book,
horrifying book published about 20 years
ago called the rape of nanking,
which is while the woman who wrote it
committed suicide.
So that sort of suffices to tell you
what the rape of nan king is about and
it's a story about the japanese in world
war ii going into a chinese kitty's city
called nan king where I believe about
350,000 people were killed.
And the nazis in that story where the
good guys.
So you can imagine the kind of brutality
that might be an been occurring there.
But there's absolutely perfectly well
documented evidence suggesting that the
japanese soldiers engaged in competitive
brutality.
You know.
And so really what happened was the
japanese had been pretty militarized by
world war two and nate adopted a
prussian education system and the
prussians and the germans,
you know,
pre,
pre 20th century germans,
they were basically interested in
educating obedient soldiers,
you know,
because it was a militaristic culture
and the japanese kind of adopted that
because they were sick of being kicked
around by the europeans and pretty
successfully because they defeated the
russians,
you know,
in the early stages of rural or of the
20th century.
It wAs quite a shock to everyone in
europe and,
you know,
cause for great celebration in Japan and
no wonder.
But anyways,
they militarize the hell out of their
young men and taught them basically that
the japanese were a master race,
you know,
and that other people were subhuman.
It's,
it's a very common human way of
thInking.
By the way.
I would say it's really the default way
that human tribes think about other
tribes.
You know,
I mean,
it's a little more complicated than that
because human tribes tend to trade with
other tribes.
So it's not all demonization,
but a lot of it is,
you know,
and if you look around the world in the
anthropological literature,
what you see Is that the names that most
tribes have for themselves is something
like that human beings or the people you
know,
indicating that the rest of the people
are reading people,
god only they're barbarians or you know,
they live out where the sun is being
eaten by the dragon of the night or
something like that.
And you know,
the word barbarian is a,
is a word that comes from the greeks
making fun of how non-greek spoke,
you know,
they thought they went bar bar,
bar,
something like that.
So anyways,
what good.
All phone was that?
The chimps,
like the chimp adolescents in particular
in particular,
the males would patrol the borders of
their territory in groups of three or
four and with often with a female or
two,
but the females didn't seem to be really
the,
they weren't,
they were more part of the group rather
than the initiators.
But what the chimps would do is if they
found a chip from another troop,
even if that was a chimp that had moved
from their troop in the not too distant
past and joined another,
because sometimes the males leave and
sometimes they go to other troops.
If they are numbered them,
they would tear them to pIeces and it
looked like that's why they were doing
the border patrol.
They're looking for trouble there.
Gangs roughly speaking,
they're looking for trouble.
But the point of it is,
is that,
and they would only attack if they
outnumbered because chimps can,
I wouldn't say they count,
but they have a rudimentary notion of
group size.
You know,
I don't think you can count without
being able to verbalize,
but you can estimate at a glance.
And so,
you know,
when I mean,
when I say tear apart,
that's exactly what I mean.
There's no upper limit on the brutality.
And so good all discovered that first.
And she didn't tell anybody about it.
Now she had her reasons.
I mean some of them I think
radiological,
oh the lovely chimps,
you know,
and fair enough.
But some of it was also she thought that
maybe the chimps had been corrupted as a
consequence of their contact with human
beings and that their natural behavior
had been somehow transform,
you know,
and that's not,
it's reasonable to be cautious if you're
a scientist before you go out and say,
hey,
chimps go to war.
Isn't that revolutionary?
Because it is,
right?
Because it just,
it just ends.
The idea that our warlike and malevolent
nature is a function of culture.
Like if chimps do it well,
what did they perverted by their own
culture?
I don't think so.
You know,
I mean there are more and less violent
chimp cultures and there are more and
less violent baboons culture.
So there is some cultural variation.
But since goodall's time,
this sort of behavior is being
documented on many,
many chimp troops.
So that's us in a nutshell and it's not
self evident that if you put the typical
adolescent male say who's not a very
well formulated personality and you
know,
because he's not that individual and you
he hasn't seen much of the world and the
typical guy that goes into the army is,
you know,
he's kind of on the margins of society.
Maybe he's not particularly bright and
I'm not trying to be insulting by that,
but you know,
it's not exactly a high end job.
You put someone that like that either
place where there's no rules.
It's like who leads where.
There are no rules while the probability
that it's the friendliest,
nicest people is very,
very low.
and so what seemed to happen in nan king
was the japanese soldiers took their
cues from the people with the most
brutal imaginations.
So you know,
when people can have pretty brutal
imaginations,
especially when they start to compete.
So,
so I was interested in that.
You know,
what exactly was at the core of that
malevolence mean,
and I think it is uniquely human.
The chimps.
So go tear another chimp apart,
but basically they just,
they're just,
they're going to kill him,
you know,
that's their goal and maybe it takes a
while,
but it's not going to take four weeks.
Whereas if you're a human being,
you know you can draw out your enemies
death for a very,
very long period of time and part of
that is the desire to produce the misery
and suffering that's attended on the
death and only human beings have the
imagination to do that.
That's why I think,
and we'll return to this.
That's why I think that in the book of
genesis,
when people's eyes are open and they
become self conscious,
they always are all always all solar.
Learn the difference between good and
evil.
Once your eyes are open and you know
what you're like,
once you know you're naked and
vulnerable,
then you can exploit that in other
people.
And only human beings have that kInd of
knowledge.
So the fact that we know that we can be
hurt makes us particularly dangerous.
Because if I know how I can be heard,
I sure know how you can be heard.
So you know,
it's a nasty situation and then of
course I'm kind of interested in the
motivation for that.
So you know,
you look at the columbine kids for
example,
and you know,
the mayhem and they produced was trivial
compared to the mayhem they were
planning.
You know,
if it was up to those two guys,
they would have bombed detroit flat
that,
you know,
they,
they had visions of doing exactly that
and it was immediate spectacular.
And they didn't do it because they were,
you know,
poor kids in some sense who were
bullied.
That is an idiotic explanation.
It's not true.
You know,
everybody's at bloody outsider.
You know what I mean?
I'm sure there isn't a single one of you
that don't have a memory from junior
high where you were an outcast in one
way or another,
maybe some of the word,
but it's very,
very common.
And to think of that as sufficient
motivation to,
you know,
shoot people cold bloodedly in high
highschool.
Sorry,
that's a little on the naive side.
So I'm very,
very interested in what makes up that
motivation.
You know,
because malevolence plus nuclear weapons
is not a good combination and so it
doesn't really look to me like we can
afford that kind of unconscious
malevolence anymore because we're just
too damn powerful and if the wrong
person ends up being like that with the
wrong weapons,
it's like game's over.
So
I've also become convinced while I'd
been looking through this,
that the problem that we're discussing
is not associate logical problem or a
political problem or an economic problem
because you know a lot of what you read
and a lot of political scientists who
tell you this sort of thing because
they're basically almost always closet
marxists.
They'll tell you that the reason for for
struggle for competition between nations
economic and I think that's observed not
because it isn't true,
but because it doesn't actually address
a more fundamental issue,
which is okay,
well economic struggle is a struggle
about who has access to what's valued,
but there's nothing self evident about
what's valued.
That's the problem.
It's like you know,
you have the idea of natural resource.
It's like oil is not a natural resource
till you have an automobile.
You know,
I mean the interplay between cultural
values,
structures,
and what constitutes a natural resources
so tightly put together except for maybe
air and water that saying,
well,
there are natural resources which means
things of intrinsic value and that's
what people fight over.
Well,
you,
you did,
you made the mystery mystery disappear
inside the word natural resource,
but you haven't solved anything.
So the question is,
well,
why would people fight over things that
they value?
Well,
because there's all sorts of things you
could value,
like peace for example.
So it's not a suFficient explanation and
uh,
and it's also not clear to me that
people's primary motivations are
economic.
you know,
it's one element of motivation.
It's not trIvial,
but I would say the motivation isn't
even really economic.
It's more related to dominance,
hierarchy position.
And that's fundamentally a sexual
motivation,
especially for men because men are
higher up in the dorm,
male dominance hierarchy,
then women are much more attracted to
them.
so you could make,
you could say,
well that's economics.
I don't think it is.
So this economic is just a secondary
consequences of that.
And I don't believe by the way that
that's a theory because there's
excellent documentation on hyper
aggression in adolescent males and the
best evidence suggests that adolescent
males become hyper aggressive when you
put them in situations where they can't
win and then they become hyper
aggressive and ended attempt to
formulate a dominance hierarchy so that
some of them can rise to the top and
basically be attractive.
So you can call that economic if you
want.
But I think it's,
I think you're pushing your luck with
that sort of explanation so.
Well.
So that's basically the background.
So when I was investigating this,
I first started studying political
science,
you know,
and I actually liked that quite a bit in
the first couple of years because
they're just basically reading political
philosophy,
you know,
and it's actually worthwhile reading
great political philosophers because a,
they could think and that's a really
good thing.
And b,
you think like they think even if you
don't know it,
right?
Because one of the hallmarks of a great
philosopher is that his ideas or her
ideas sink into the culture so deeply
that like 100 years after they've
written,
everybody just thinks they always
thought that way.
Like that'S one of the thIngs say that's
happened to freud.
I mean everybody kind of understands
that there's an unconscious and that
people are motivated by sexual,
you know,
sexual drive.
It's like,
what?
So,
you know,
what's so brilliant about that?
Like,
well yeah,
it's obvious ones.
Freud points it out.
No.
So.
So anyways,
I started,
I took political science first and
literature,
which I found was also extremely useful
because great literary people have great
things to say.
Like dostoevsky mean what his novels
just absolutely flattened me.
He's so brilliant and I've never read
anyone who takes moral question so
seriously,
like.
So for example,
if you look at crime and punishment,
which is a book I would highly
recommend,
dostoevsky is the absolute model of a
true intellectual.
And I say that because in crime and
punishment for example,
dostoevsky has this character named
roscoe and off and you guys can identify
with risk.
and the call to some degree because he's
about your age and he's a university
student now.
He's having a rough time because he's in
st petersburg and he doesn't have any
money and he lives in this tiny little
room which has basically a bunch of
clothes on the bed that he can sleep in
and he's starving to death.
It can only,
only has bread to eat and he's a law
student so he's having a rough time,
you know,
in st petersburg,
the end of the nIneteenth century is
kind of a rough place.
So he hasn't,
some of you guys probably have is pretty
bad,
but was calling the call.
I've had it pretty bad.
And so he's half starved and half
delirious.
And,
and he's also very,
his ideas are very adult because he's
one of the first russians who really
considered themselves an atheist.
So,
you know,
Russia was a medieval society until the
late name,
19 hundreds.
it was sorta like quebec before 1950.
[inaudible] before 1960.
And I'm serious about that because
quebec was really the last european
country,
so to speak,
that underwent a secularization.
And that happened in in about 1960 and
quebec families went from an average
size of about 12 to 13 to about one
point two lowest birth rate in the world
and see all the quebecois while we're
married and none of them are now and
they were all catholic and hardly any of
them are now and was an overnight
transformation.
And that's partly what fed quebec
nationalism because there was actually a
study that was,
or a study that was released by gallup
organization.
I only heard it referred to in one
meeting where they indicated that if you
were a lapsed catholic and in,
in,
in quebec,
you were 10 times more likely to be a
separate that that's really worth
thinking about,
right?
Because religion collapses and what
happens is nationalism just rises up to,
to take its place because you'd need a
bloody belief structure because what
else?
What are you going to do?
Wander around aimlessly.
That's not fun.
It's not useless are useful,
you know,
so you just jumped from one structure of
belief to another or you fall apart.
So.
So that's also something that's very
much worth knowing.
Finding ways,
so all risk on the cog.
He thinks he's a pretty educated guy and
he's pretty smart and he is pretty
smart,
but he's like smart,
arrogant,
not smart wise because he's 21.
What the hell does he know?
He doesn't know anything but he's smart
and he's contemptuous of other people
because he can probably smarter than
most of them,
you know,
and he confuses that with health,
with knowing what's going on.
And so he lives in this little horrible
apartment and he has a horrible landlady
and she really like this is where is a
genius.
Like cove hates his landline and then
dostoevsky tells you why and you'd
think,
well yeah,
I'd hate her too.
So she's
miserable.
She owns a bunch of apartments.
She charges too much rent for them.
She tortures all the people that rent
from her in every possible way she can,
but places are filthy.
She doesn't provide any furniture.
She hoards money and doesn't do anything
with it.
So she lives in absolute poverty and you
know,
and,
and in film and she's a cruel person in
every possible way.
Plus she has this nice who isn't very
bright,
you know,
same intellectually impaired and she
basically treats her like to slave so
she's not doing anyone any good and
that's where to nicholson and then he
gets a letter from his mother and his
mother basically tells them that his
sister is going to go marry this rich
guy because she's in love with him and a
battle solve all of his monetary
problems so he can keep going to law
school,
but he reads between the lines and you
know,
he realizes pretty quiCkly that this
rich guys are real like miserly scum rat
and he's going to treat his sister and
his mother absolutely miserably.
And his sister doesn't really love in
many Ways and the only reason she's
marrying him so that risk all knockoff
can go to school.
So he's not very happy with that and you
know,
fair enough,
you know,
you can understand his motivation.
So he starving and he's full of these
ideas.
Also the sort of meat chicken,
you know,
so and like atheistic ideas hit Russia
really hard because it went from
seriously orthodox christian and every
possible way to unbelievably skeptical
in one generation and it just,
it just fractured the society.
It's partly why communism became so
absolutely attractive for the russians
and dostoevsky also details that
extremely brIlliantly in a book called
the possessed of the devils.
So it's a wonderful book.
It's hard to get into.
You have to read about 200 pages before
it really kicks in,
but you know,
that's.
And all those sorta like that.
So anyways,
risk on the curve is he's thinking these
sort of superman ish rationalistic ideas
and he thinks,
well,
you know,
there's no evidence that there's any
real moral hierarchy and you can easily
make a case that the reason that people
aren't really moral,
they're just cowardly.
And this is a nietzschean observation,
right?
Most of what you call your morality
isn't morality all.
It's just too,
you're too afraid to do what you want
and because you're too,
we easily to admit that you say that you
don't do those things because your
moral.
but it isn't true.
You'd love to do them if you were brave
enough,
you just aren't.
So people misread that to say that what
nisha thought was that all morality was
cowardice.
that isn't what he thought.
He thought that all cowardice
masquerading as morality,
that's a whole different thing.
So anyways,
recall the call is thinking about these
things and he's thinking,
well I could be a lawyer and I'd be a
good one.
I'd help people.
I'd help the poor people you know,
and,
and what the hell good is it for me to
wander around starving like this and it
doesn't seem reasonable and,
and my is going to go basically
prostitute herself for this rich guy and
that sucks.
And there's my landlady and she's an
absolutely reprehensible creature and
everyone agrees and she's old and worn
out and it's like,
and she has this person,
she keeps us a slave.
Although maybe I should just get rid of
her.
And what I love about that is that like
this happens almost all the time
in universities,
I would say,
but it really between and whenever you
hear people who think they're smart have
a discussion,
what they generally do is they have an
idea and then they have an idea about
the person who has a different idea.
And the idea about the person who has a
different idea is that their idea is
stupid.
And so what they do is they produce.
They're caricatures of that person's
idea and then they blast it and they
think,
wow,
I won that argument,
which is really pathetic.
It's a straw man argument.
It's the sign of a weak mind.
What you do if you really want to have
an argument with someone is you help
them.
LIke let's say you're a right winger and
you're arguing with a left winger or
you're a left winger and you're arguing
with a right winger.
It's like
you want to make their argument as
magnificent as you possibly can and then
see If you can undermine it.
That's what you do because then you're
getting somewhere like any idiot can
make a straw man in light it.
Dostoevsky never does that.
He makes the people that he's like,
when he sets up two ideas to go to war,
he embodies both sets of ideas in the
most powerful characters he could
imagine.
So in the brothers karamazov for
example,
the two people,
the two protagonists basically there's a
bunch of them but one is named leo osha
and the other is named ivan and now osha
is kind of an innocent guy.
Goodguide fundamentally a little on the
naive side,
religious but not in a way that he can
defend,
you know,
it's more of a natural expression of
spirit and he's in a monastery and he's
the follower of this famous monk and you
know,
he's kind of into orthodox christianity
and his
benevolent and sincere way,
but he's not much of an intellect.
And ivan,
his older brother,
like ivan's got everything.
He's good looking.
He's tall.
I believe he's a soldier.
Like he's an impressive guy and he's got
a viciously cutting intellect and he
just tears leo shoW apart every chance
he gets across the whole book and you
know,
you can see the two parts of dostoevsky
fighting it out in the book because part
of dostoevsky was highly spiritualized,
not least because he was epileptic and
that often for reasons we'll talk about
later that often exaggerate
spirituality,
but also because he was like,
he was a deeply spiritual person and
also a tremendous intellect and so he
was at war inside and he put those parts
of emoting into these characters and let
them just go at it.
And it's brilliant.
You know,
I even makes the best argument for
atheism that's ever been written.
It's really powerful.
You know,
he taught.
Basically what he does is he talks about
all these terrible things that were
being done to children in Russia at the
turn of the century.
Back in the late 19,
18 hundreds.
You know,
he talks about this one situation where
the parents of this young girl locked
her in a freezing out house overnight
and she was crying and screaming and
telling them that she was sorry,
and they just left her in there and she
froze to death and it was like front
page news and in Russia at the time,
I guess probably in moscow or maybe in
st petersburg and dostoevsky lifted that
argument.
TheN said to he had ivan asked leo ships
like,
okay,
well thIs is the sort of thing god
permits.
okay.
He said,
the whole damn world isn't worth that.
The suffering of one child in a
situation like that,
how can you possibly see that something
like that can exist and wander around
with your bone headed belief in a
benevolent god what's up with you?
Would you like a girl in our house
overnight and let her freeze if that
meant that other people would be happy,
you know?
And,
and of course ldl osha says,
well,
no,
I would never do that.
And so I even tell some,
well,
yeah,
you know,
you wouldn't do that,
but this god that you imagined exists
would be perfectly pleased to let
something like that occur.
You know,
ellie osha has no idea what to say about
god and you're either that,
you know,
that's just a fragment of ivan's
argument.
He's like punching at him like map,
you know.
And I think the way on the osha
basically responds is by trying to live
a good life,
you know,
he can't,
he can argue are even better at it than
he is in.
Plus there's this vicious strain of
critical thinking about religion,
religion that's being lost it in from
western europe.
You know,
there's 300 years of philosophical force
behind it.
And ivan is its mouth bass.
It's like ellie osha and Russia itself
is just blown apart by that.
They have no defense against that.
You know,
the bloody western europeans had 300
years to get used to it.
The russians had like 10 years solely
just frank fragmented them,
you know?
And they were like waiting for the new
messiah and they sure got one.
I know.
And both dostoevsky and in each.
You prophesied about what would happen
in Russia for 40 years before it
happened.
That's bloody amazing to be,
to think that you could look that far in
the future and actually get it right.
You know,
I mean,
things didn't change quite as fast and
as they are now,
but you know,
it wasn't like victoria,
the victorian times were static,
you know,
there were a lot of things going on and
so to get that right over four decades,
it's,
those guys were in touch with something
very deep that was going on underneath
the substrata of,
of,
of western civilization.
So.
All right,
so you know,
I'm thinking about belief structures and
I'm thinking about mlevel incident.
I'm thinking about
the psychological role that these sorts
of things are playing,
you know,
because it occurred to me at some point
something like an idea,
something like this.
And this actually tormented me for about
six months I would say,
when I'd been thinking these things
through.
and I guess it was for probably five
years at this point.
And I was really obsessed by it.
I was thinking about this literally
every minute of the day from the time I
woke up until the time I went to sleep.
It was really manic probably.
But so I,
I got,
I got at one point I got to this
conclusion.
I thought,
okay,
well here's the situation.
It'S pretty obvious that people need
belief structures because first of all,
a belief structure orients them to
action,
right?
So you have to believe that one thing is
more valuable than another just to af.
Right?
So why did the chicken cross the road?
Well,
it's because he thought the other side
of the road was better than this.
It was on.
Obviously,
you know,
because whenever you're moving,
the implicit hypothesis of your movement
is that the thing you're moving towards
is better than the thing you're leaving
and you know,
unless you're self destructive because
otherwise why bother?
And so what that means is you don't move
without a value structure and you don't
get to not have one.
You might say,
well,
I don't believe in anything.
It's like,
well no.
You say you don't believe in anything.
So technically you can't make an
argument for what you believe or you
don't know what you believe,
but if you're not just sitting there
vegetating than you believe something
because otherwise because you act it
out,
right?
So
you have to have a belief system
or,
or you fall apart.
Right?
So your nihilistic or depressed or
hopeless?
Not certainly like who wants that?
That's not good.
It's painful.
Depression is no joke.
No.
I know someone who had a very,
very serious illness is an illness that
destroyed parts of this person's body,
destroyed their joints and they were
also had clinical depression.
And I asked this person at one point,
okay,
you get to get,
you get to have a choice.
You can get rid of the illness that's
destroying your joints.
So they had to be replaced or you can
get rid of the depression.
He said I'd get rid of the depression
first.
No problem.
So that's where thinking about,
right?
So if you believe nothing,
you're hopeless,
you've got no values structure to place
you end up is not good.
And I'm sure lots of you have
experienced that.
You know,
I mean most people,
especially the people who are likely to
come to this class,
most people by the time they're your
age,
I've gone through a dark period or to,
you know,
for whatever reason relationship breaks
up or maybe you lose the meaning in your
life for someone betrays you or someone
gets sick or you get sick or you know,
some tragedy comes along and knocks you
flat.
You think,
what the hell?
What's going on?
Why is any of this worthwhile?
And it's a good question.
Okay,
but you can't go there because that's
like death.
while then the other problem is,
well,
let's say you do have a belief system.
All right,
so what happens if I have a different
one?
What are we supposed to do about that?
You can't give up yours because then
you're done.
I'm not going to give up mine for the
sAme reason,
but it isn't clear that we can inhabit
the same part of the earth peacefully if
we don't believe the same things.
So I,
when I sorted that oUt,
I thought,
oh,
well that'S it man.
We're baSically,
that's it.
We'Re done.
Because you can't not have a belief
system and if you have one you can't not
fight and we're too well armed to fight
now and we're not jUSt going to collapse
into nihilism,
although you know that happens quite a
bit.
So games over.
Well,
it turned out that that was wrong,
thank god,
but it took me an awful long time to
even begin to understand how it could
possibly be wrong because as far as I
could tell,
those were the options.
So another thing we're going to try to
figure out is not only you know exactly
why it people have belief systems
exactly what a belief system is and why
they compete and why you can't just get
rid of them,
but we're also going to figure out what
it is that you might be able to do about
the fact that you're going to inhabit
places with people who don't have
exactly the same belief system as you
know.
And in some sense it's really the
problem with social being right.
And creatures have been trying to solve
this problem ever since.
Well,
we don't know for how long I like to use
lobsters as an example because lobsters
arrange themselves into dominance
hierarchies and they have very complex
social behavior and they don't have much
of a brain,
so you can.
You can have pretty damn complex social
behavior without having much of a brain.
And lobsters have been around for 400
million years.
So us roughly speaking because we had To
shared ancestor with a lobster,
you know,
a very long time ago.
We've been trying to figure out how to
coexist with other creatures that don't
precisely share our belief systems for
400 million years and we'd been
sufficiently successful about it so that
we're both social and here we are.
So obviously there's ways that it can be
dealt with.
Although I don't think we necessarily
understand them very well and part of.
So I didn't want to just understand what
it was about belief systems,
you know,
about their necessity and their function
and the way that they become
pathologist.
I wanted to figure out if there was also
a pattern to the processes by which
belief systems are modified and
negotiated so that the belief systems
that have different structures can
coexist in the same place peacefully and
it's a vital question,
right?
Because most of you are going to get
married successfully or unsuccessfully,
and even if you don't,
you're going to live with someone for a
long period of time and you're gonna.
Find out that they're not like you and
that's extremely annoying,
but you know what are you going to do?
You're either gonna be a slave or a
tyrant or you're going to negotiate
because those are your options and
negotiation is extraordinarily
difficult,
right?
Because you have to figure out what you
want and probably won't even admit it,
and second of all,
you have to listen to your stupid
partner telling you what they want and
then you have to try to figure out how
you're going to make both of them
possibly.
Well,
slavery,
tyranny.
That's comparatively easy from a
cognitive perspective compared to
actually trying to figure out How you
can be mutually satisfied in the same
space,
but you can do it.
That's the thing.
There is a process and it's
identifiable,
so I want to talk to you about belief
systems and their psychological
significance,
what they're like,
what function they perform,
but I also want to talk to you about how
they transform because they do,
right?
They changed especially with humans so
they can change.
That means they can modify and that
means at least in principle,
that we could have a dialogue.
Now dialogue is,
and that's rough,
but the alternative is war.
Right?
And that's partly why you're supposed to
listen to your enemy because if you
don't listen to your enemy,
the only other thing that you
can do is fight with them.
That's it.
You mean it's the desire for that to
happen?
Well,
I would say it's partly the desire for
that to happen.
The thing is whenever I look at a
political movement,
especially the ideological,
I think,
okay,
there's a bunch of things your for fine.
What are you against?
You know,
because one of the things that people
who adopted maybe theological position
like to presume is that all of the right
is on their side and that makes them
very unconscious up their shadow,
let's say from a union perspective.
The nazis had all sorts of positive
reasons for what they were doing,
but you know,
the negative reasons were there too and
you could easily make a case that the
negative reasons were really the
reasons.
And when I look at ideologues,
I always think,
yeah,
that's what you're for sure.
But I,
I don't believe all the good people are
on your site and be.
I know that negative motivations are
more powerful than positive ones.
So you say you're for things,
but you're against them too.
So let's,
let's start with that.
So I thought I started thinking about
this after I read george orwell.
I love george orwell,
by the way.
How many of you know who george orwell
is?
Wow.
Really?
That's impressive.
How many don't?
Okay,
well that's,
that's good.
That's amazing.
I'm like,
how the hell did you learn about george
orwell?
Is it 19,
84?
Fundamentally or animal farm?
Animal farm.
Okay.
Well that's good because george orwell,
man,
I tell you,
george orwell was the first western
intellectual who figured out what the
hell was going on in the soviet union.
And he did that in the mid forties,
early,
you know,
it was complicated because we sort of
knew what was happening in the twenties
and the thirties,
you know,
there was len and then that wasn't so
good.
There was the russian civil war,
there was the idea of universal
communism that wasn't such a good idea,
you know,
for,
as far as people who didn't want to be
communists were concerned.
And then there was what happened in the
Ukraine in the 1930.
So it was like,
you know,
the evidence was starting to pile up.
But unfortunately what happened was the
spanish civil war and the lefties were
pretty much the good guys in the spanish
civil war.
Right.
It was like a microcosm of the second
world war.
The lefties were fighting the fascists
and some of the lefties were communists,
but a lot of them were also people who
were,
I think genuinely fighting for freedom
and a lot of north american literary
figures went to Spain to fight on the
side of the,
you know,
against the fascists.
And so faIr enough,
you know,
the fascist,
we're obviously,
you know,
reprehensible clearly and so and so that
kind of muddied the water right because
the fastest were bad.
And then that sort of means that people
that are fighting them,
their guard and some of them are
communists and there was good.
There is pretty good reason for people
to be radical socialist at that point in
human history because the plIght of the
working man was relatively unpleasant.
George orwell wrote a book called road
to wigan pier and he went up to this
town that was a coal mining town and he,
he stayed with the coal miners for
awhile and just looked at their life.
So here,
here's pArt of their life.
So you basically work a seven and a half
hour shift when you're a coal miner and
you think,
oh,
that's not too bad by 1930 standards.
it's like,
yeah,
except you have to go down to the coal
mine tunnels,
you know,
and like they're not eight feet high and
carpeted there like four and a half feet
high and rough and poorly lit and the
air is terrible.
And so basically you have to chimp walk
or crawl up to three miles just to get
to work and then you have to do that at
the end of your shift and you don't get
paid for that.
That's just,
that's your Commute,
right?
Right.
So you know,
it was no bloody well.
and then of course what you're doing
when you get there,
it's like it's absolutely filthy.
It's unbelievably noisy.
It's brutally difficult.
He said coal miners,
they have no teeth because they're like,
because of their living conditions,
but their bodies were absolutely
perfect.
They were unbelievably powerful and
strong because all they did was
incredibly intense physical labor,
but it was bloody rough.
ANd the housing,
those people had like
50 families for one outhouse,
that's probably good enough to describe
it and often they were row houses and
the row houses had no back doors that
they had no paths between them and all
the old houses were at the back.
So that meant if you were with like 20
below and it was the winter and you were
sick,
then you get to go all the way around
the block to your damn outhouse.
Or maybe there'S only one there and you
light up with 50 people.
So that you know.
Yeah.
So an orwell,
he was orwell was an upper class guy
basically,
and he was trying to help themselves
overcome these upper class prejudices
and who is a real documentary,
one of the terrible working conditions
of,
of working class people.
And he wrote this book called road to
wigan pier.
But one of the things that orwell said,
he wrote this story about these poor god
damn coal miners.
and you think,
well yeah.
It's like how about some social
legislation so that these people In
their children aren't just absolutely
brutalized nonstop?
No.
But then he wrote the last half of the
book and he wrote it for the left book
club,
which was a socialist group that the
publisher book every month or so.
And what he did was he.
He wrote a critique of socialism,
a pretty socialism.
And he said,
yeah,
well this sucks man.
It's like we should be on The.
Sorry to these working people,
but the socialists,
I mean they're not on the side of the
working people.
They're like tweed wearing middle class
hyper intellectuals who never go
anywhere near the working class because
of their class.
Prejudice isn't for all sorts of other
reasons and they don't like the poor at
all.
They just hate the rich.
And I thought I'd been a member of the
ndp for a long time.
At that point.
It was always something a little off
about is especially the more radical and
that works with you guys.
Like it just doesn't look like
benevolence as far as I can tell.
There's a lot of whining and complaining
and resentment.
It's like,
whAt's that?
What's that about?
I read orwell and I thought,
right,
if you hate the successful,
if you hate the rich who were rich by
the way is whoever has more money than
you.
That's how you defined rich,
and the best way to mask your resentment
is to pretend that you're on the side of
the poor.
And are I read that.
I thought that's exactly right.
And then that's part of also what made
me psychoanalytically oriented because
one thing psychoanalysts always do
always is if you say you're,
here's how I'm positively predisposed.
The psychoanalyst says,
how are you using that to mask something
easy and malevolent that you're doing?
And that's always,
that's a very,
very useful questions.
Not always correct,
right?
But,
but it's correct a lot more than people
generally like to think,
you know,
it's like the mothering him grant the
mother or the witch in hansel and
gretel.
You know the story,
right?
This guy gets married,
he's got a couple of kids.
His new wife doesn't relate to the kids.
You have 100 times higher chance by the
way of being abused by a step parent.
Then biological parent,
just so you know.
So the,
the step where they're just like the
kids,
she tells the guy,
well why don't you just go with those
kids out in the woods,
sold out.
They go out in the woods.
So they're lost kids,
right?
They have nowhere to go.
So when they're wandering around out
there in the forest and what happens,
they come across a gingerbread house.
You think,
wow man,
you're a starving kid.
Gingerbread house.
That's good news,
right?
Not only is it a house,
but it's made out of candy.
How could anything possibly be any
better?
So when they go,
well,
and then there's this grandmotherly type
care and you know,
she starts to fatten them up and she
puts,
I think it's handling the cage and
she gets gretel after awhile to
basically work as their scullery maid.
And it becomes quite obvious to the
children that she's actually fattening
them up so that she can put them in the
oven and eat them.
And so I think what hansel does is I
think griddle gives him this leg bone
from some animal and the old witch's
half blind.
And every time she reaches into sorta
feel his laying,
he gives her the bone and so like she's
just not all that interested in meeting
them in anyways.
The kids end up pushing her in the oven
and closing it and getting the hell out
of there.
So you know,
it's a happy ending as far as fairy tale
skill.
But it's an eternal story,
right?
It's a classic story,
but it needs a whole family.
Be bloody wary of people who do too much
for you.
Right?
It's like if have a mother or any other
relative for that matter,
who's fattening you up on mercy and
candy?
The probability that her basic goal is
to eat you enough so that you never
leave.
The probability is extraordinarily high
and that's no joke.
You know,
one of the things that you do learn if
you read about the sorts of people who
burst out of their mother's basement and
go shoot up dawson colleges that often.
That's exactly the situation that you've
been in,
right?
They're burning with resentment in your
uselessness down in the basement for
five or six years.
You know,
they don't have to leave,
they don't have to become independent,
everything's done for them,
so they never have to do anything for
themselves.
It's like it's not pretty.
And so one of the rules for dealing with
people,
and I know this is actually a rule for
dealing with elderly people in,
in,
in hopes for,
for,
for retired people,
is do not do anything for anyone they
can do for themselves.
You are stealing from them when you do
that.
And it's a great rule of thumb for kids.
Like once they can dress themselves,
they dress themselves.
If they can set the table,
even if it takes 20 minutes,
it's like they're setting the table.
You're not doing them a favor by helping
them do anything they can do themselves
and it skips.
It's kind of harsh,
you know,
but it beats the hell out of the witch
in hansel and gretel.
So.
So anyways,
you know,
one of the things we're going to look at
as well as the dark side of positive
motivations.
So
now how are we going to do this?
Hmm.
One of the things you might ask yourself
is,
how in the world do you know if
something is true?
Now,
the first thing I would suggest is that
the attitude you guys should bring to
this class is that nothing that I tell
you is true.
Okay?
Now,
I don't mean that you should be
arrogantly skeptical because that's not
appropriate,
but you should bring every critical
faculty.
You have to bear on what I tell you to
see if you can chip away at it because
what you want to do,
you want to build yourself a body of
knowledge that you cannot undermine,
and the way you do that is by trying to
undermine it,
by hacking away at the foundation with
everything you've got,
and if,
if the ideas can withstand a total
onslaught,
then you've got something.
You've got a foundation,
you've got something you could stand on
that's going to be there when things get
rough,
and so I'm going to tell you what I've
found.
It's been useful to me when things got
rough,
but I don't expect you to assume that
that's gonna work for you and I don't
want you to to like I want you to listen
and to think,
but I want you to keep your wits about
you.
Now I'm going to tell you how I go about
trying to determine whether or not
something is true.
First of all,
there's different definitions of truth
and so we're gonna basically flipped
back and forth between two.
One of truth is an objective definition
and we don't have to talk much about
that because you guys already know what
that is,
but there's another definition of truth
that the.
I think the best way of defining it is
as pragmatically true and pragmatism is
a branch of american philosophy and it's
a very sophisticated brands and
philosophy.
In fact,
I actually think it's the most
sophisticated brand philosophy part part
probably because it makes the least
claims and what the pragmatists state
basically is.
Well,
you don't really know anything,
right?
You don't have ultimate knowledge about
anything,
so your knowledge always bought himself
in ignorance.
And so then the question is,
well,
how do you know them if anything is
true?
And the pragmatist would say,
well in a sense you don't.
What you know always is if something is
true enough for a particular function.
So for example,
your theory about getting to the door
might be that you can stand up and walk
there and you might.
Well god only knows what might happen on
the way there.
You know,
maybe there'll be an earthquake or a
ceiling tile fall on you.
Or,
or who knows,
maybe I'll have a heart attack,
you know,
so you don't know whether you can get
there.
You can infer from past experience.
But if you get there,
then what you can say is my statement
about truth was sufficient so that the
outcome was what the theory predicted.
And so in some sense,
what the pragmatists are saying is every
time you make a statement,
especially if it's related to action,
that you will offer a theory of truth
along with that statement implicitly,
which is that this is true enough if
what I predict happen happens.
And so it's really,
it's a binds very nice theory because it
doesn't require you to be omniscient
about anything for things to be true
enough and you are ignorant.
You don't know everything about
anything.
And so obviously you're working in the
world with partial knowledge and it
works not all the time.
You get old,
you get sick,
you die.
Like I mean you're,
you're,
you're not going to work it out
thoroughly.
But
so we're going to use the pragmatic
truth framework and we're going to use a
objective truth framework.
And one of the propositions that I'm
going to make to you is that the stories
that are associated with our deepest
moral intuitions are pragmatic truths
and that you need pragmatic truths and
you need objective truth.
And you need pragmatic trees because you
don't just need to know what the world's
made up.
You need to know what to do about the
fact that the world is made out of
things.
And because you know,
human beings are creatures.
We act in the world.
We act on the world.
And so what we need to know is how is it
that you should act on the world and
that is not a question that can be
addressed by objective methods
technically,
right?
Because it's actually a value question.
What should you do?
Science by its very methodology refuses
to answer such questions.
And you know,
people confuse the fact that science is
value free,
sort of with the idea that existence is
value free.
It's like that's,
that's,
that's philosophically primitive,
I would say,
because science was actually set up to
get rid of the value of the subjective
value in its,
in its technique.
So you can't say,
well we set this thing up to get rid of
the value would look all the value
score.
It's like there's no value.
It's no,
no,
no.
You put that domain out of the range of
consideration.
That doesn't mean it doesn't exist.
It's just,
it's just a different.
It requires different.
It requires a different philosophy,
a different outlook,
different techniques,
different tools,
different methods of proof,
all of these things.
And so part of what we're going to do,
I'm going to use objective truth as much
as i possibly can because I think that,
uh,
that a lot of what psychology as a
science has been able to offer in the
last hundred years is actually
extraordinarily useful for elucidating
some of the issues that we're going to
discuss because we really have made some
progress and understanding the psyche,
as you know,
especially at a,
I would say at a biological slash
behavioral level.
We've got some pretty solid information.
It's not perfect,
but it's helpful.
Okay.
So we're going to draw on a bunch of
sources.
We're drawing stories.
We're going to draw in literature,
we're going to draw on philosophy,
we're going to draw on religion,
we're going to draw a myth,
mythology.
We're going to draw on biology and
psychology.
And there's this idea which you should
have learned about if you're a
psychologist called multi-method
multitrack matrix.
So this was invented by a guy back in
the 19 fifties,
I think it was neil and chronback,
his famous paper that was published in
the fifties.
Everyone is supposed to know it.
No one ever pays any attention to it,
but what they were interested in was how
do you know if when you say that
something exists,
like let's say a anger,
does anger exist?
Well,
the answer seems self evident.
Yes.
Well it's tricky,
you know,
because generally no one comes up to you
and says anger,
you know,
they tell you a little story where they
use words relating to anger in the story
and then you sort of derive what they
mean by angry from the context and the
context is important in defining the
reality.
Right?
So you don't know if that,
that the central idea anger can be
pulled out of the context and then you
can say,
well that's a thing.
Like,
like iron is a thing or like mercury is
that thing,
you know,
because maybe it's not.
Maybe it's a pattern or maybe it's
something that's a convention or you
know,
there may be all sorts of things that
are,
that are associated with it.
So one of back in meals,
fundamental claims was that in order to
determine whether or not something
existed,
you had to be able to detect it using
different methods.
Now it's tricky because it's not obvious
what constitutes a different method,
right?
So you kind of have to make a judgment.
But I would say you use a multi-method
multitrack means of determining what's
true with your senses.
How many do you have?
Six cars.
Yeah.
Pro proprioception,
right?
Why?
Why,
why?
Well,
let's say for the sake of simplicity,
why one on one?
Uh,
to increase the likelihood of it being
true,
you could see something but not be able
to touch it.
That might be a mirage maybe or a
multiple reasons for it to be pointing
to the probability of it.
Yes.
Well,
that's exactly it.
And you want it to be.
So the sense ideas are really good.
One because you can see that census used
different modalities,
right?
It's like obviously the ice relying on
electromagnetic radiation and the ears
rely on vibrations in the air and
touches really an atomic phenomena in
some sense.
You know,
because you're feeling the outer
surfaces of electrons with your
electronic surfaces and there's taste
which is again,
a molecular level phenomena and smell
and you know,
so our idea,
connie,
is if,
if all five of those things detected,
it's sufficiently real so that we can
use it to guide our action and we won't
be wrong.
So it's five dimensions.
You need a five dimensional analysis and
that's evolved.
So you might say,
well,
you know,
that's.
Let's call that a good estimate.
You need five ways of detecting
something before you can be sure it's
true.
Now you know when you're learning about
experimental psychology,
they tell you p is less than point.
Oh,
five,
right?
You use a measurement and then you
determine whether the probability that
that has manifested itself exceeds a
certain level of chance.
If it does,
then the thing exists,
but that's,
that's actually not right.
It's not right for experimental
psychology and experimental
psychologists have known it since the
late fifties.
You have to demonstrate that the damn
thing exists multiple different ways.
Now.
What constitutes a different way can be
subject to debate.
It's a complicated thing to sort out,
but you can kind of figure it out,
right?
You know,
maybe you as a physiological measurement
and self report or something like that
or you self report and other report or
you know,
and maybe you don't need five,
but you probably need three or something
like that,
you know,
depending on them.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to
tell you a story roughly speaking and I
want to make this story evident at five
or six different levels of analysis and
I want to show you how the story is the
same and all of these levels of
analysis.
Now the one,
one of the potential flaws of that
method is this.
So Joseph Campbell,
for example,
he wrote about here on mythology,
right?
Some of you from undergrad,
the hero with a thousand faces and one
of the criticisms of Joseph Campbell and
people like him that they read the
stories of multiple cultures,
but they have an a priori framework.
And because of the high priority
framework,
they only see what their theory tells
them that they're going to see.
They don't look for the exceptions,
so it's a problem with pattern
recognition,
right?
You may be able to recognize patterns
where they don't exist.
Now my method could,
could be criticized on that grounds I
think,
but the way I've tried to protect myself
against that was to make sure that I
drew from this enough diverse sources so
that the probability that I would be
able to tell a coherent,
coherent story across all those
different types of methods is
vanishingly small.
Now you're going to have to decide if
you think that's true.
So,
um,
and I can,
I can tell you roughly the dimensions of
analysis.
The idea is that I'm going to talk to
you about.
I've put into practice personally.
They worked for me.
They work for the people that I've
taught them to.
so those are family members often,
but not only family members,
lots of other people because I'm also a
clinician.
Right?
And so it seems to work quite nicely.
I have a lot of people write to me and
tell me that the ideas have worked,
you know,
and so,
so I've got multi rater reliability
there and then I think it's manifests
biologically and I think it's manifest
culturally and I think it's manifested
in these very,
very old stories and anthropologically
and so forth.
So,
you know,
make up your own mind,
you,
you can see,
you know,
and I think the other,
the other thing,
and I don't really know what to do,
what to make of this,
you know,
sometimes you have an intuition of
truth,
right?
It's like maybe you're describing a
problem to someone and they say,
well this seems to be at the heart of it
and they give you a formulation and
kinda goes click and you think,
yeah,
that's how all those things hang
together.
It's a,
it's a pattern recognition mechanism.
It's insight mechanism.
People generally have the feeling that
when something like that happens,
that something of truth has been
revealed.
Now a very common response from the
students I've had in these courses is
that I never tell anyone anything they
don't already know.
So,
and I think the reason for that is I'm
hoping the reason is,
is that what I'm outlining our
archetypal structures,
you know,
and I've drawn a lot of my work from you
who was very interested in our critical
structures.
And so what should happen,
and I think it will happen,
is when I tell you a story,
you'll think,
oh yeah,
right,
that's what that means and I see and
here's all the things that it explains.
And so you'll have this sense and that's
the,
you talked about your friend with the
spiritual awakening.
Often one of the cognitive phenomena
that accompanies a spiritual awakening
is the connection of many,
many diverse phenomena into a
overarching unity.
And you feel that like as a radical
simplification or something like that,
a decrease in entropy or something like
that.
And a very,
very powerful sensation.
So,
I mean there's other sources of what you
might call spiritual experience as well,
but that's certainly one of them.
And so you can see,
you know,
all you stories,
you can think,
oh well,
you know,
how,
how does that story manifest itself in
your experience?
Now it's a phenomenal logical level of
truth,
right?
So the phenomenologists branch of
philosophy started by heidegger,
not exactly,
but let's say extended as well as anyone
extended it by heidegger.
Heidegger thought that western
philosophy had gone wrong basically
since the time of socrates,
which is quite a long time,
and he said that we were,
we became interested in what the world
was made of and how we knew things and
what we should have been interested in
stead was the nature and quality of
being and whaT he meant by being isn't
the objective world.
What he meant by being was the manner in
which you have experience and so there
are elements of being that aren't
objective elements and so I would say
pain is a phenomenological reality,
right?
It's,
it's not something you can.
You can Index it objectively,
but the index is not the phenomena and
you know,
is your pain real.
See,
this is.
This is a question for people who think
there's no such thing as meaning.
Like you try to argue yourself out of
pain and see how far you get.
You might think,
well,
that's not the sort of meaning I meant.
It's like,
you know,
a negative meaning is a place to start,
right?
because if something's negative and it's
real,
it does imply that there's something
positive.
It's real.
It might be harder to get ahold of.
At least it's not pain,
you know,
so,
but pain descartes,
and I'll close with this.
You guys can have a break.
Descartes
implemented a method he called radical
doubt when he went on his philosophical
journey and what descartes looked for
was one thing he couldn't doubt because
he was probably clinically depressed and
he was just doubting everything.
It's like,
well,
why?
How do I know the world isn't just been
mirage made by an evil demon to,
you know,
to,
uh,
to obfuscate reality from me.
While his conclusion was the one thing
that he could not dispute was that he
could,
he was an could think.
Now,
I don't think descartes really meant
what we meant by think.
I think he meant more what we would mean
by experience because thought has become
a much more narrowly defined,
you know,
term since the time of descartes.
So I don't think he meant,
I think therefore I am.
I think he meant something like I
experienced.
I have experienced there for him.
But regardless of that,
modern people think about it as thought
heidegger was different.
Heidegger basically said the one thing
you can dispute is that that experience
is your experience.
It exists.
You can't.
It's almost by definition,
right?
It's like the definition of exist.
And then he was interested in what the
fundamental elements of existence I've
existed.
It's work and they're not on just like,
you know,
like the fundamental elements of the
objective world.
There are more things like pain and for
me that was the thing that stopped me
from delhi.
It's like a candle.
Don't be existence of pain.
It seems real.
And I might say it seems more real than
anything else.
Now you might say you don't believe
that,
but I would say,
I don't care what you think you believe,
I'll watch you when you're in pain.
And every single one of your actions
will indicate that you believe in it.
And not only that,
you can't not believe in it.
Right?
It's there and it's there so much that
well,
that's a meaning and so that it's in
that way that heidegger,
at least in part thought of existence as
or experience as composed of meetings
and so part of the reason that this
course is called maps of meaning is
because one of the things we're going to
look at is the structure of meaning and
we're going to start with negative
meaning because from my perspective
it's.
Look,
you can doubt whether or not good
exists,
but once I'm done telling you about the
things I know about human history,
there won't be a single person in this
room who thinks that evil doesn't exist
and you might think that's a bloody
horrible thing to learn,
but it's not.
It's unbelievably useful because once
you can establish something that you
cannot deny,
then you can move from that and I think
you can hypothesize that if you're
capable of detecting radical evil,
I'll tell you about unit seven,
31 at some point or you can look them up
yourself.
I wouldn't recommend it.
By the way.
Once you can identify radical evil and
you think,
well,
that's just beyond a doubt,
that's reprehensible.
There's no justification for that
whatsoever,
no matter what,
whenever.
Well,
then you've got something to stand on
and you can start thinking,
well,
what's the absolute opposite of that?
Then,
you know,
it might be,
how is it that you could conduct
yourself so that in your sphere of
influence,
the probability like that anything like
that would ever happen is reduced to the
absolute maximum.
Well,
that's a reasonable moral question.
And,
and,
and I,
I don't think it's something that you
can dispense with,
with like a casual nihilism.
I don't think a nihilist can dispense
with it because he even nihilists
suffer.
Thank god for that.
You know,
it's their only,
it's their only source of potential
salvation.
Sometimes they notice it,
oh,
I'm suffering about all this nihilism.
Maybe that indicates that there's
something flawed in it.
It's always possible.
So.
Okay,
so let's take a break.
We'll take a break for.
Oh,
come back at three.
What time is it?
I want to make sure my clock,
the 58.
Okay.
Come back at 3:15.
We'll see you there and then I'll talk
to you more about the technical elements
of the class.